so I have a lot of questions to ask uh
you about the journey towards this
historic progress towards peace with the
Abraham Accords but first on this
situation to step back at some of the
history uh is there things about the
history of Hamas and Gaza that's
important to understand what is
happening now just your comments your
thoughts your understanding of Hamas I I
think you did an excellent job Lex of of
really giving the summary just a couple
things maybe I'll add to it is that
Hamas was originally founded uh from the
Muslim Brotherhood in Egypt uh which is
a group that's caused a lot of issues uh
in the region um they've uh they've
attacked Israel many times in the past
there's a lot of discussion about how
Israel uh is an occupying power well in
Gaza in 2005 they withdrew from all the
land and then they say Israel is an
apartheid state well Israel then gave
governance of the region to the
Palestinians and then what's happened is
is the Palestinian people's lives have
now gone down not up since then uh I
will say that under uh hamas's
leadership uh in in Gaza the people who
have suffered the most are the
Palestinian people and I see I've I've
watched cries uh throughout my time in
government from people saying we want to
see the Palestinian people live a better
life I agree with those people I think
that the Palestinian people in Gaza are
essentially hostages in uh in Gaza you
have basically 2. you know 2 million
people that are being held hostage by
30,000 Hamas terrorists and that's
really the problem and I would just
encourage people to uh to push their
attention and energy in this moment and
their anger towards Hamas those are the
people who are killing innocent
civilians who are uh murdering
indiscriminately and those are the
people who have held back the
Palestinians from having a better life
and just finally what I would say is you
know what we saw with Hamas was that if
you go back to 2007 they basically had
just one plan that they did over and
over and you know we were very careful
to try to monitor very closely and stop
the Iranian money and the resources from
coming in and again we took a little bit
of criticism from the International
Community from keeping the Border tight
but unfortunately every time you'd allow
construction materials to go into Gaza
they'd use them to build tunnels not
homes you would have equipment that
would come in to build pipes they turn
it into bombs so
um it was very very hard to figure out
how do you get the resources into Gaza
to help people live a better life while
at the same time the leadership in Gaza
was taking all those resources and
turning it into military equipment to
attack
Israel